NEIL: ALL RIGHT, THE BORDER IS
STILL A MESS.
BETTER THAN 2 THE MILLION, AS
YOU KNOW, A RECORD NUMBER OF
MIGRANTS CROSSING INTO THIS ONE.
THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE LIKELY THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
SO-CALLED GOTAWAYS, BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION SEEMS TO BE
FOCUSED ON THE ROUGHLY 24,000
VENEZUELANS TRYING TO GET HERE
AND TRYING TO REIN AT LEAST THAT
NUMBER IN ESPECIALLY SINCE A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
VENEZUELANS LIKE TO CLAIM ASYLUM
TO EASE THEIR WAY HERE OR AT
LEAST GET THEM IN HERE TO
ADJUDICATE THEIR CASE.
THE RIO GRANDE CITY, TEXAS,
MAYOR JOINS US NOW.
MAYOR, THIS SUBSET OF THE
MIGRANT POPULATION COMING INTO
THE COUNTRY AND THE FACT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS FOCUSING ON
THAT, I'M SURE YOU WOULD WELCOME
ANY FOCUS ON THE BORDER AND
ANYONE TRYING TO GET IN HERE,
BUT THAT CONTINGENT, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> WELL, GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON YOUR
PROGRAM.
AND WE MUST CALL IT FOR WHAT IT
IS, AND THIS IS BIDEN'S
RENDITION OF REMAIN IN MEXICO
2.0.
AND IRONICALLY, BIDEN IS
FOLLOWING TRUMP'S LEAD WHICH, BY
THE WAY, REMAIN IN MEXICO IS
HIGHLY EFFECTIVE IN MANAGING
LARGE INFLUXES OF MIGRANTS.
AND CURRENTLY, WE ARE
EXPERIENCING RECORD NUMBERS OF
APPREHENSIONS, OVER 2.2 MILLION.
NOW, THE FLIP SIDE IS THAT
REMAIN IN MEXICO IS NOT A
PERMANENT SOLUTION FOR OUR
BROKEN IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
HOWEVER, IT IS BENEFICIAL WHEN
OUR MIGRANT PROCESSING
CAPABILITIES ARE OVEREXTENDED
AND COMPROMISED AND, COP
SUBSEQUENTLY, JEOPARDIZING OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
SO, ABSOLUTELY, WILLS A
COMPONENT WILL.
AND AND -- THERE IS A COMPONENT
THERE.
AND WE MUST ADDRESS OUR BROKEN
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM, AND I KNOW
WE'VE HAD THESE CONVERSATIONS
BEFORE.
BUT NONETHELESS, AT THIS POINT
IS IT TOO LITTLE, TOO LATE?
I DON'T KNOW.
BOTTOM LINE, THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS AS A
COUNTRY.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS OUR ASYLUM
LAWS, OUR IMMIGRATION LAWS, OUR
VISA PROGRAMS, VISA OVERSTAYS
THAT ACCOUNT FOR ALMOST HALF THE
POPULATION LIVING IN THE U.S.
ILLEGALLY.
AND WE HAVE CLOSE TO A MILLION
ANNUALLY.
SO BOTTOM LINE, THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE MUST -- WE
NEED TO DO AND, UNFORTUNATELY,
WE HAVEN'T DONE IT THUS FAR.
AND I KNOW WE'VE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION THAT BOTH POLITICAL
PARTIES HAVE FAILED TO PRIOR
TIDES THE OUR BROKEN IMMIGRATIOR
BROKEN IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
BUT BOTTOM LINE, WE NEED TO TAKE
ACTION.
NOT WORDS, NOT PROMISES, NOT
RHETORIC, ACTION.
OF AND NOT BROWNS, BLACKS OR
WHITES, NOT AS REPUBLICANS OR
DEMOCRATS, BUT AS AMERICANS.
CAREFULLY MANAGE THE BALANCE
BETWEEN IMMIGRATION AND BORDER
SECURITY WHICH CAN MUTUALLY
COEXIST.
WE JUST HAVEN'T FOUND THE MIDDLE
GROUND.
NEIL: YEAH, YOU'RE PROBABLY
RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
BUT, MAYOR, DOES MEXICO NEED TO
TAKE ACTION AS WELL?
DO YOU THINK THEY HELP THIS
PROCESS?
AS YOU KNOW, THEY'RE NOT KEEP ON
THIS IDEA THAT A LOT OF THESE
VENEZUELAN ARES AND THEIR CASES
ARE GOING TO BE HANDLED IN
MEXICO WHICH, AS YOU RIGHTLY
POINTED OUT, DOES SEEM TO BE
GOING BACK TO THE POLICY OF THE
TRUMP YEARS.
BUT I AM CURIOUS AS TO WHETHER
YOU THINK THEY'RE MAKING THIS
SITUATION WORSE.
I MEAN, AFTER ALL, THE
OVERWHELMING NUMBER OF MIGRANTS
WHO MAKE THEIR WAY TO OUR SIDE
OF THE BORDER PARIS MAKE --
FIRST MAKE THEIR WAY TO THE
SOUTHERN SIDE OF THE MEXICAN
BORDER FROM GUATEMALA AND POINTS
SOUTH.
AND IT DOESN'T APPEAR THAT
MEXICO DOES ANYTHING TO STOP
THAT.
FINISH.
>> WELL, WE MUST WORK WITH
MEXICO AND THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE
COUNTRIES TO COUNTER THESE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING OPERATIONS AND
GATHER INTELLIGENCE.
AND MEXICO IS WILLING TO BE A
PARTNER IN THIS.
HOWEVER, WE NEED TO ABSOLUTELY
SIT DOWN WITH THEM AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION BECAUSE THERE ARE
MANY ELEMENTS TO IN THAT
BENEFITS BOTH COUNTRIES.
SO IT IS SOMETHING THAT DO --
NEIL: BUT WE'VE HAD THOSE
CONVERSATIONS, HAVEN'T WE,
MAYOR?
WE HAVE THE CONVERSATIONS.
I'M JUST WONDERING, DO THEY
IGNORE US?
MAYBE THINGS ARE BEING DONE
BEHIND THE SCENES THAT I'M
UNAWARE OF, BUT ARE THEY DOING
CAN AS MUCH AS THEY COULD BE
DOING?
>> AT THIS POINT I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE -- YEAH, YOU SAID THERE
HAVE BEEN CONVERSATIONS, BUT
WHAT EXACTLY DID THEY HAVE THE
CONVERSATIONS ON IN I DON'T
KNOW.
HONESTLY, I DON'T KNOW THE
INFORMATION.
HOWEVER, THE PEOPLE THAT I'VE
WORKED WITH -- BY THE WAY, I DO
MAKE MANY TRIPS TO MEXICO WITH
MY COUNTERPARTS HERE, MAYORS,
AND WE SIT DOWN AND HAVE
CONVERSATIONS.
AND GUESS WHAT?
BOTH, WE HAVE MUTUAL
UNDERSTANDINGS OF WHAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN HERE AT BORDER, AND THEY
DO SHARE MANY OF THE SAME
CONCERNS, SECURITY, SAFETY,
TOURISM, COMMERCE.
AND GUESS WHAT IN THEY'RE --
WHAT?
THEY'RE WILLING TO WORK WITH US.
I WORK VERY WELL AND CLOSELY
WITH THE MAYORS RIGHT ACROSS THE
BORDER HERE.
SO, HONESTLY, I DO NOT SEE WHY
THE GOVERNORS OR THE PRESIDENT
OF MEXICO WOULD NOT HAVE, ARE
OPEN TO THE CONVERSATION OF
SITTING DOWN AND WORKING THIS
OUT.
BECAUSE MEXICO BENEFITS TOO BY
HAVING A GOOD WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE U.S.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN TRADE AND EVERY
CONCEIVABLE COMMODITY AND
SERVICE, DESTINATION, ANYWHERE,
USA.
HERE AT OUR OWN TWO-LANE BRIDGE
HERING IT'S OTHER A BILLION
DOLLARS IN TRADE, AND THAT'S
JUST ONE SINGLE BRIDGE.
BUT WE HAVE SO MUCH, SO MANY
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE CAN WORK
WITH MEXICO, AND THIS IS ONE OF
THEM.
AND THEY ARE OPEN TO IDEA THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS IMMIGRATION
AND, ABSOLUTELY, HAVE A HOLD ON
IT BECAUSE IF NOT, WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE
ISSUES.
NOW, ANOTHER THING, BY THE WAY,
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
ADDRESSED TOO.
ACCORDING TO THE U.S. BUREAU OF
LABOR STATISTICS, EMPLOYMENT IS
PROJECTED TO GROW BY 12 MILLION
JOBS.
THE FUTURE CRISIS WILL BE LABOR
SHORTAGES.
IT'S GOING TO BE A --
NEIL: WE'VE GOT TO ACT, WE'VE
GOT TO ACT ON THIS, TO YOUR
POINT, MAYOR.
THANK YO